let's say this past year I started a
restaurant and I now want to think about
what type of a profit I've been making
it that restaurant we're going to think
about it in two different ways we're
going to think about it in terms of an
accounting profit which is really the
type of profit that most of us associate
with a business or a firm and we also
think about it in terms of economic
profit which we'll we'll see is a little
bit different and instead of telling us
whether a business is producing income
it tells us whether it makes sense to
even run the business in the way that we
are actually running it so first let's
focus on the traditional way of
calculating profit so let's say my firm
my restaurant my firm is a restaurant in
year one it brings in in revenue in
revenue it brings in $500,000 so revenue
literally is the amount of money the
customers pay me to eat at the
restaurant they are paying for their
dinners this is literally though the
money that's coming in the door
sometimes people call it the top line
because it's literally the top line of
our income statement I just wrote it
it's the top line now we have to think
about our expenses expenses expenses now
when you're starting or when you're
running a restaurant one of the obvious
expenses is going to be the cost of food
so food we're going to say cost us
$100,000 $100,000 and you have the cost
of labor I have the weight staff and I
have the chefs and the Busboys and all
those people in this past year I spent
$100,000 then I have and I'm going to
assume that I don't own the building
that I rent the building so building
rent so I'm assuming this is on the
building let's say that that was
$200,000 and then finally I really just
rented everything I also rented the
equipment all of the stoves the the
fridges and all of that stuff so I've
got none of this stuff that I own so the
equipment rent equipment rent I spent
another $50,000 so how much profit do I
have here and those are all my expenses
I didn't borrow any money and so I
didn't have any interest expense or
anything like that how much profit do I
have before paying tax or essentially my
pre-tax profit and the reason why we
think of in those terms is because your
your the amount you pay in tax
usually derived from your pre-tax profit
and that depends on where where this
business is what country what state what
type of business it is and the easy way
to calculate pre-tax profit pre-tax
profit and this is pre-tax and we're
thinking in terms of accounting profit
right over here is we take how much
money comes through the door and then we
have to subtract out all of the all of
them payments we essentially have to
make to other people and what we have
left is our pre-tax profit and so
500,000 minus the C minus 450 gives us a
pre-tax profit in that same bright
yellow of $50,000 and I'm assuming that
I'm the only owner of this business and
so I can essentially take it all out for
myself and maybe help pay my own
personal rent or whatever else or I
could take some of this or all of this
and reinvest it back in the business
maybe I start buying my equipment or I
expand in some way who knows what I
might do with that money and this is
just traditional accounting profit this
is how profit is calculated all this is
a super simple example the future I'd
like to do more nuanced examples in the
accounting world but this you referred
to is just a counting profit accounting
profit when people in the in the real
and the in the everyday we will talk
about profit this is normally what
they're talking about now when
economists talk about profit they're
talking about something slightly
different and the best way to realize
that is to just calculate economic
profit for this exact same business or
this firm as an economist would call it
and a firm really is a general idea for
an organization that is trying to
maximize profit so once again it's year
1 actually let me just copy and paste it
so it's year 1 that's our revenue so I'm
going to copy and I'm going to paste it
so this right over here so far so good
looks pretty similar but now we're going
to think about things in a slightly
different way economists view cost in
terms of opportunity costs and as we'll
see some of the opportunity costs you
can measure in terms of dollars but some
are less explicit so I'm going to write
here just so we can get in the
economists frame of mind opportunity
opportunity costs and within opportunity
cost or they're going to be explicit
opportunity cost is an implicit
opportunity costs so first let's do the
explicit explicit opportunity costs well
actually all of these are explicit
opportunity cost so let me just copy and
paste that so I will copy copy and paste
so all of these are explicit opportunity
costs and the reason why they are
explicit is I'm actually making up I'm
paying money for all of these things
even the equipment and the and the rent
of the part I don't own it I'm actually
paying I'm paying whoever does on it I'm
these are these are direct outlays out
of the business I'm explicitly making
these payments and the reason why we can
think of them as opportunity costs even
though they're given in dollar terms is
that if I'm spending a hundred thousand
dollars on food that's a hundred
thousand dollars that I couldn't spend
on something else if I'm starting a
hundred thousand labor that's a hundred
thousand dollars that I couldn't spend
on something else so I'm just measuring
the opportunity cost in terms of dollars
but dollars that I could have spent on
other things but so far it looks pretty
much identical I'm just viewing it with
a slightly different lens but you're
like well what's the big deal here well
we're going to see a little bit of
divergence when we start think about the
implicit costs that really weren't taken
into account here the implicit
opportunity cost especially implicit
implicit costs so if I'm running this
business and let's say that in order to
run it I actually had to focus on it
full-time I couldn't have I couldn't
have actually quit my job then this
there's an implicit cost of an implicit
opportunity cost of the job that I gave
up or my wages foregone so let me write
this down wages wages foregone and let's
say and this will depend on who we're
talking about but let's say I was a
doctor and I was making a nice steady
risk-free $150,000 a year so I was
giving up 150 thousand dollars a year
now we've calculated we've listed all
the X percent and the implicit
opportunity cost now we're ready to
calculate our economic profit so let me
draw a line over here so our economic
economic profit is going to be our
revenue that we're taking in - all of
these expenses that gives us positive
$50,000 but now we have to subtract the
wages foregone
so then I get to negative $100,000 now
this is interesting this is kind of a
big discrepancy here one in in
accounting terms I'm profitable in
economic terms I'm not profitable and
the important thing to realize is
economic profit when it's negative isn't
saying or you could say that this we're
have a hundred thousand economic loss or
an economic profit of negative one
hundred thousand this isn't saying that
the business or the firm isn't spitting
out money what it is saying is it
probably doesn't make sense to run this
business or at least run this business
in this way if this was neutral if this
was zero that means hey it's probably
making money but you're kind of neutral
whether you whether it makes sense to
run it this way or not if it's positive
that means it definitely does make sense
to to run the firm in this way and then
it is definitely doing better than all
of the all of the alternatives so this
right over here is saying look you're
making fifty thousand dollars a year
that's the fifty thousand dollars that
you have to spend if you're the owner or
reinvest in the firm this is saying
essentially look you could have been
making more money than that hundred
fifty thousand dollars instead of making
fifty thousand doing this you could have
been making a hundred thousand dollars
more doing something else so you are
essentially giving up you are giving up
one hundred thousand dollars to do this
restaurant so if you're a rational
decision-maker and you really are about
maximizing your profit this actually
might not make so much sense for you